Naval warfare in the future could be waged
by robotic eels.
And scientists at the University of Colorado
have discovered an invisible doughnut-shaped
shield roughly 7,200 miles above Earth - comprised
of high energy-electrons and protons that
protect us from "killer electrons!“
Vsauce! Kevin here - this is Mind Blow.
Every password you use can be replaced by
your eyeball. Myris converts the one-of-kind
characteristics of your iris into an encrypted
code unique to you. The device stores no data,
not even an image of your eye, so you won’t
have to worry about someone stealing your
password. And it features a significantly
lower false ID acceptance rate compared to
voice recognition, fingerprints or facial
recognition at 1 in 1.5 million. So no more
usernames - no more passwords - only eyeball.
This Lego Body is controlled by an implanted
worm brain. The Open Worm project has mapped
the connections between the worm’s 302 neurons
and simulates them in software. The Lego robot
mimics the behavior of an actual worm, ceasing
to move when its nose sensor bumps into a
wall, avoiding being touched, and moving forward
when its food sensor is stimulated. This could
someday lead to technology that simulates
a human brain, which would revolutionize computers
and artificial intelligence.
An 800 page book from 1692 contains a hand-painted
archive of every color. Created by someone
known simply as “A. Boogert” it was intended
to be an educational guide on how to mix and
identify colors. Find the link below to view
the entire book in high res.
Ultrasound creates 3D objects that can be
seen and felt in mid-air. Developed at the
University of Bristol - it focuses complex
patterns of ultrasound and these shapes can
be felt and manipulated in real time. Potential
for this includes allowing surgeons to explore
a CT scan by feeling a disease such as a tumor.
Eva is the world's first smart shower device.
Designed to save water, it can be attached
to any existing shower head, and uses motion
sensors to adjust how much water flows depending
upon how close you are. They claim it save
up to 50% of water usage and it can also monitor
water temperature so the shower starts exactly
as warm as you like it.
Electric eels discharge electricity similarly
to a taser. They stuns their prey with high
voltage 10-15 millisecond pulses, and can
use electricity to force hiding animals to
give away their locations. They overwhelm
the nerves that control the muscles, causing
them to involuntarily contract. They're basically
biological tasers.
Full facial transplants are possible thanks
to 3D printing. A 3D model of a patient’s
head is constructed using CAT scans and then
printed which tells surgeons where the vessels
are to match the tissues perfectly - which
is integral in the healing process of transplanting
a new face. And nine of these procedures have
occurred in the US since 2011.
Researchers in South Korea have developed
an artificial skin designed to mimic real
human skin. The stretchable polymer features
networks of sensors made of gold and silicon
that senses touch, pressure, and moisture.
It could give artificial limbs feeling and
even has a layer of actuators that warm it
up to the same temperature as human skin.
Stanford University researchers have created
a climbing system to scale walls like a gecko.
The sticky-pads were inspired by gecko toes
which are extremely sticky due to being covered
with thin, long spatula-shaped structures
that increase surface area and amplify electrical
attractions between the toes and a surface.
This adhesive could be used to make grippers
for manipulating huge objects without the
need for suction power or chemical glues.
Finally, VeloX 3 is a human-powered bicycle
capable of reaching 83 mph and the team at
Delft University is currently working on breaking
their own record with VeloX IV.
I am holding a stainable chain in my hand. This is a special chain developed by DSM. The rollers, are made of a stainable plastic.
To lower the friction, and steel to steel friction is higher than the steel to plastic friction. So what we have 1 like 1% in efficiency.
This will contribute definitely to getting higher speeds.
I’m gonna leave you with a virtual reality
game inspired by lucid dreaming - and as always
- thanks for watching!